good morning everybody and thanks for
being here this morning as you know on
March 22nd a special counsel robert
muller concluded his investigation into
matters related to russian attempts to
interfere in our 2016 presidential
election and he submitted his
confidential report to me pursuant to
department regulations as I said during
my Senate confirmation hearing and since
I'm committed to ensuring the greatest
degree possible of transparency
concerning the special counsels
investigation consistent with the law at
11:00 this morning
I'm going to transmit copies of the
public version of the special counsels
report to the Chairman and ranking
members of the Senate and House
Judiciary Committee's the Department of
Justice will also make the report
available to the American people by
posting it on the department's website
after it has been delivered to Congress
I'd like to make a few comments today on
the report before I do that I want to
thank Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosenstein for joining me here today
and for his assistance and counsel
throughout this process rod as you know
has served at the Department for nearly
30 years with dedication and distinction
and it's been a great privilege and
pleasure for me to work with him since
my confirmation he had well-deserved
plans to set back from public service
that were interrupted by my asking him
to help in my transition rod has been an
invaluable partner and I am grateful
that he is willing to help me and has
been able to see the special counsels
investigation through to its conclusion
thanks rod
I'd also like to thank Special Counsel
Robert Muller for his service and the
thoroughness of his investigation
particularly his work exposing the
nature of Russia's attempts to interfere
in our electoral process as you know one
of the primary purposes of the special
counsels investigation was to determine
whether President Trump's campaign or
any individual associated with it
conspired or coordinated with the
Russian government to interfere in the
2016 election volume one of the special
counsels report describes the results of
that investigation as you will see the
special counsels report states that his
quote investigation did not establish
that members of the Trump campaign
conspired or coordinated with the
Russian government in its election
interference activities I am sure that
all Americans share my concern about the
efforts of the Russian government to
interfere in our presidential election
as the Special Counsel report makes
clear the Russian government sought to
interfere in our election process but
thanks to the special counsels thorough
investigation we now know that the
Russian operatives who perpetrated these
schemes did not have the cooperation of
President Trump or the Trump campaign or
the knowing assistance of any other
American for that matter that is
something that all Americans can and
should be grateful to have confirmed the
special counsel report outlines two main
efforts by the Russian government to
influence the 2016 election first the
report details efforts by the internet
research agency a Russian company with
close ties to the Russian government to
sew social discord among American voters
through disinformation and social media
operations following a thorough
investigation of this disinformation
campaign the special counsel brought
charges in federal court against several
Russian national
and entities for their respective roles
in this scheme those charges remain
pending and the individual defendants
remain at-large but the special counsel
found no evidence that any American
including anyone associated with the
Trump campaign conspired or coordinated
with the Russian government or the IRA
in this illegal scheme indeed as the
report states quote the investigation
did not identify evidence that any US
person knowingly or intentionally
coordinated with the IRAs interference
operation unquote put another way the
Special Counsel found no collusion by
any Americans in IRAs illegal activities
second the report details efforts by the
Russian military officials associated
with the GRU the Russian military
intelligence organization to hack into
computers and steal documents and emails
from individuals associated with the
Democratic Party and Hillary Clinton's
campaign for the purpose of eventual
eventually publicizing these documents
obtaining such unauthorized
following a thorough investigation of
these hacking operations the Special
Counsel abroad chart Court
Russian military officers for their
respective roles in these illegal
hacking operations those charges are
still pending and the defendants remain
at large
but again the special counsels report
did not find any evidence that members
of the Trump campaign or anyone
associated with the campaign conspired
or coordinated with the Russian
government in these hacking operations
in other words there was no evidence of
the Trump campaign collusion with the
Russian government's hacking the special
counsels investigation also examined
Russian efforts to publish stolen emails
and documents on the Internet
the special counsel found that after the
GRU disseminated some of the stolen
documents to entities that it controlled
DC leaks and gusoff ur to the GRU
transferred some of the stolen materials
to WikiLeaks for publication WikiLeaks
then made a series of document dumps the
Special Counsel also investigated
whether any member or affiliate of the
Trump campaign encouraged or otherwise
played a role in these dissemination
efforts under applicable law publication
of these types of material would not be
criminal unless the publisher also
participated in the underlying hacking
conspiracy here to the special counsels
report did not find that any person
associated with the Trump campaign
illegally participated in the
dissemination of the materials finally
the Special Counsel investigated a
number of links or contacts between the
Trump campaign officials and individuals
connected with the Russian government
during the 2016 presidential campaign
after reviewing these contacts the
special counsel did not find any
conspiracy to violate US law in
rushon linked persons and any persons
associated with the Trump campaign so
that's the bottom line after nearly two
years of Investigation thousands of
subpoenas hundreds of warrants and
witness interviews the Special Counsel
confirmed that the Russian government
sponsored efforts to illegally interfere
with the 2016 presidential election but
did not find that the Trump campaign or
other Americans colluded in those
efforts after finding no underlying
collusion with Russia the special
counsels report goes on to consider
whether certain actions of the president
could amount to obstruction of the
special counsels investigation as I
addressed in my March 24th letter the
special counsel did not make a
traditional prosecutorial judgment
regarding this allegation instead the
report recounts 10 episodes involving
the president and discusses potential
legal theories for connecting those
activities to the elements of an
obstruction offense after carefully
reviewing the facts and legal theories
outlined in the report and in
consultation with the Office of Legal
Counsel and other department lawyers the
Deputy Attorney General and I concluded
that the evidence developed by the
special counsel is not sufficient to
establish that the president committed
an obstruction of justice offense
although the Deputy Attorney General and
I disagreed with some of the special
counsels legal theories and felt that
some of the episodes examined did not
amount to obstruction as a matter of law
we did not rely solely on that in making
our decision instead we accepted the
special counsels legal framework for
purposes of our analysis and evaluated
the evidence as presented by the special
counsel in reaching our conclusions in
assessing the president's actions
discussed in the report it is important
to bear in mind the context
president Trump faced an unprecedented
situation as he entered into office and
sought to perform his responsibilities
as president federal agents in
Secours were scrutinizing his conduct
before and after taking office and the
conduct of some of his associates at the
same time there was relentless
speculation in the news media about the
president's personal culpability yet as
he said from the beginning there was in
fact no collusion and as the special
counsels report acknowledges there is
substantial evidence to show that the
president was frustrated and angered by
his sincere belief that the
investigation was undermining his
presidency propelled by his political
opponents and fueled by illegal leaks
nonetheless the White House fully
cooperated with the special counsels
investigation providing unfettered
access to campaign and White House
documents directing senior aides to
testify freely and asserting no
privileged claims and at the same time
the president took no act that in fact
deprived the special counsel of the
documents and witnesses necessary to
complete his investigation apart from
whether the acts were obstructive this
evidence of non corrupt motives weighs
heavily against any allegation that the
President had a corrupt intent to
obstruct the investigation now before I
take questions I want to address a few
aspects of the process for producing the
public report that I am releasing today
as I said several times the report
contains limited redactions related to
four categories of information to ensure
as much transparency as possible those
redactions have been clearly labeled so
that the leaders can tell the readers
can tell which redactions correspond to
which categories now as I recall those
categories are six immaterial grand jury
material information that the IC
believes would disclose sources and
methods information that would impair
the investigation
execution of other cases that are
underway and finally information that
implicates the privacy and reputational
interests of peripheral third parties as
you will see most of the redactions were
compelled by the need to prevent harm to
ongoing matters and to comply with court
orders prohibiting the public disclosure
of information bearing on ongoing
investigations in criminal cases such as
the IRA case and the Roger stone case
these redactions were applied by
Department of Justice attorneys working
closely together with attorneys from the
special counsels office as well as the
intelligence community and prosecutors
are handling the ongoing cases the
redactions are their work product no
redactions done by anybody outside this
group there were no redactions done by
anybody outside this group no one
outside this group proposed any
redactions and no one outside the
department has seen the unredacted
report with the exception of certain
sections that were made available to IC
the intelligence community for their
advice on protecting intelligence
sources and methods consistent with
long-standing executive branch practice
the decision whether to assert executive
privilege over any portion of the report
rested with the President of the United
States because the White House had
voluntarily cooperated with the special
counsel significant portions of the
report contain material over which the
president could have asserted privilege
and he would have been well within his
rights to do so following my March 29th
letter the office of the White House
Counsel requested the opportunity to
review the redacted version of the
report in order to advise the President
on the potential invocation of privilege
which is consistent with long-standing
practice following that review the
president confirmed that in the interest
of transparency and full disclosure to
the American people
would not assert privilege over the
special councils report accordingly the
public report I am releasing today
contains redactions only for the four
categories that I previously outlined
and no material has been redacted based
on executive privilege
in addition earlier this week the
president's personal Council requested
and was given the opportunity to read a
final version of the redacted report
before it was publicly released that
request was consistent with the practice
followed under the ethics and Government
Act which permitted individuals named in
a report prepared by an independent
counsel the opportunity to read the
report before publication the
president's personal lawyers were not
permitted to make and did not request
any redactions in addition to making the
redacted report public we are also
working with Congress to accommodate
their legitimate oversight interests
with respect to the special counsels
investigation we have been consulting
with chairman Graham and chairman Adler
through this process and we will
continue to do so given the limited
nature of the redactions I believe that
the publicly released report will allow
every American to understand the results
of the special counsels investigation
nevertheless in an effort to accommodate
congressional requests we will make
available subject to appropriate
safeguards to a bipartisan group of
leaders from several congressional
committees a version of the report with
all redactions removed except those
relating to grand jury information thus
these members of Congress will be able
to see all of the redacted material for
themselves with the limited exception of
that which by law cannot be shared I
believe that this accommodation together
with my upcoming testimony before the
Senate and House Judiciary Committee's
will satisfy any need Congress has for
information regarding the special
counsels investigation once again I'd
like to thank you for being here and I
will now have a few questions
articulated and you say disagreed with
what did you disagree with him on the
eye I'd leave it to his description in
the report the special counsels own
articulation of of why he did not want
to make a determination as to whether or
not there was an obstruction of fence
but I will say that when we met with him
deputy attorney general Rosenstein and I
met with him along with IDO Callahan who
is the principal associate deputy on
March 5th we specifically asked him
about the OLC opinion and whether or not
he was taking the position that he would
have found a crime but for the existence
of the OLC opinion and he made it very
clear several times that that was not
his position he he was not saying that
but for the OLC opinion he would have
found a crime he made it clear that he
had not made the determination that
there was especially given that DOJ
policy the very prosecutorial function
and all our powers as prosecutors
including the power to convene grand
juries and the compulsory process that's
involved there is for one purpose and
one purpose only it's determined yes or
no was alleged conduct criminal or not
criminal that is that is our
responsibility and that's why we have
the tools we have and we don't go
through this process just to collect
information and throw it out to the
public we collect this information we
use that compulsory process
for the purpose of making that decision
and because the special counsel did not
make that decision
we felt the department had to and that
was a decision by me and the Deputy
Attorney General
Special Counsel Muller did not indicate
that his purpose was to leave the
decision to Congress I hope that was not
his view since we don't convene grand
juries and conduct criminal
investigations for that purpose he did
not I didn't talk to him directly about
the fact that we were making the
decision but I am told that his reaction
to that was that it was to make that
decision today today I'm really focused
on the process of releasing this
actually the statements about his his
sincere beliefs are recognized in the
report that there was substantial
evidence for that so I'm not sure what
your basis is for saying that I am being
generous to the president is there
another precedent for it okay so
unprecedented is an accurate description
why it's not here this is his report
obviously that you're talking about okay
so for he did it for me as the Attorney
General he is required under the
regulation to provide me with a
confidential report I'm here to discuss
my response to that report and my
decision entirely discretionary to make
it public
since these reports are not supposed to
be made public that's what I'm here to
discuss propriety for you to come out in
sort of what appears to be sort of
spinning the report before public